إذا انضممت إلينا للتو في إطلاق نار في
محطة مترو أنفاق
في بروكلين نيويورك ، فإن خمسة
أشخاص على الأقل أصيبوا بالرصاص ،
قيل لي إن الشرطة
تحقق في ما إذا
تم استخدام قنبلة دخان قبل إطلاق النار أو  أثناء
إطلاق النار حيث كان جيسون يقول هناك
أيضًا
يعتقدون أن مطلق النار كان
يرتدي قناع الغاز في
وقت إطلاق النار ، سنستمر في
تزويدك بالتفاصيل ويمكنك رؤية
استجابة الطوارئ هناك تلك
الصور الحية من خارج المحطة في جديد.
يورك جوزيف
جياكولون ، رقيب
سابق في شرطة نيويورك
، سؤال لك نظرًا لكيفية تغطية
كاميرات المراقبة لنيويورك الآن في
مترو الأنفاق ، لديك كاميرات خاصة وكاميرات الشرطة
في العديد من زوايا الشوارع ،
سيكون لدى الشرطة القدرة على تتبع
هذا الجاني من مترو الأنفاق إلى حد
كبير  أينما ذهبوا أو كانت نقاطهم العمياء
جيدة هناك بعض النقاط العمياء
ولكن كل الخلاصات تمر عبر ما
يسمى بمركز الجريمة في الوقت الحقيقي في نقطة
واحدة  olice plaza حتى يتمكنوا من الوصول إلى
جميع كاميرات nypd ، ستكون الكاميرات الخاصة هي
التي ستوفر المواقع الأخرى
التي لا يمكنهم رؤيتها ، لذا
سيكون هذا جهدًا جماعيًا
ربما لم نشهده منذ وقت طويل جدًا
كنت في السيارة كنت في الطرف
الأمامي للسيارة الثالثة وحدث كل شيء
في النهاية الخلفية لنفس السيارة ،
فما حدث كان بمجرد
اشتعال الدخان ، بدأ يبتلع
كل شيء بدأ الناس يهاجرون
إلى مقدمة السيارة.
السيارة وفي مقدمة العربة ، لا
أعرف ما إذا كان الناس يعرفون ذلك ، لكنه كان
أحد تلك القطارات القديمة حيث
أغلقوا الأبواب للتنقل بين السيارات ،
لذلك كان هناك رجل نبيل في القطار
يستخدم كل قوته في المحاولة  لفتح
هذا الباب
وانتهى به الأمر بفتحه ولكن الباب الآخر
للدخول إلى العربة الأخرى كان
مغلقًا
وكان هناك أشخاص في تلك العربة الأخرى
شاهدوا ما كان يحدث
وحاولوا فتح الباب لكنهم لم يتمكنوا من
ذلك.  عالق
في العربة
وأعني
أنا  لا أعرف ما إذا كان هذا فظًا جدًا بالنسبة
للتلفزيون ولكن كان هناك دماء على
الأرض
وكان هناك الكثير من الدم المتدفق على
وأنا
في ذلك الوقت لم أكن
أعتقد أنه كان إطلاق نار لأنه
بدا  مثل الألعاب النارية
أيضًا ، كان الناس
يدوسون على بعضهم
البعض في محاولة للوصول
إلى الباب حيث تم قفلها وكان
هناك الكثير من الذعر ولكن
لحسن الحظ ، تحرك القطار
بسرعة كبيرة إلى المحطة التالية
ونزل الجميع من القطار  في عجلة من
أمرنا ، نحن سعداء جدًا لأنك بأمان لتكون قريبًا
من ذلك ، أتساءل في
خضم الفوضى أن الدخان الخوف
هل رأيت
المسلح لم أر أي شيء
كل ما رأيته كان
دخانًا ورأيته  دخان ورأيت أشخاصًا
يهربون ويصرخون نحوي ،
لذلك
تحركت للتو وجلست خلف الألواح الخشبية
على جانب الكرسي بجوار
الأبواب وأبواب دخول عربة القطار
وبقيت هناك للتو ، لقد
فهمنا أن لدينا بعضًا
فيديو كنت قادرا  للتصوير ،
سنقوم بتشغيل ذلك
الآن وهنا يا إلهي
[الموسيقى]
نرى الناس هناك يغطون
أفواههم بالدخان في السيارة بينما
تتحرك السيارة بعد وقت قصير من إطلاق النار حدث هذا
الفيديو بعد  كل ما حدث من
فرقعة وإطلاق نار
والقطار
كما أتذكر ، قلت إن القطار تأخر
بين الشارع 36 والمحطة المحلية
وكان هذا عندما بدأت القطارات في التحرك
للاقتراب من المحطة
، لذا والشيء هو أنني لا أعتقد
أنه كان هناك أي شخص  ركز على
تسجيل ما كان يحدث
لأنه بينما كنت جالسًا
خلف الجزء الخشبي بجوار الباب ،
كان هناك رجل أيضًا بجواري قال إنه
يجب وضع هاتفي بعيدًا
فقط في حالة حدوث بعض الجنون
، ولهذا السبب كان الفيديو 10 فقط  لمدة ثوانٍ ،
أردت فقط الحصول على مقطع فيديو
للفوضى التي كانت تحدث هناك